president Trump is starting a new
foreign policy positions that reverse
some of his most significant campaign
promises in one day he backtracked on
previous public statements on China's
currency the American Russian
relationship and the importance of NATO
mr. Trump said that decades all Alliance
is no longer obsolete the president
spoke to reporters yesterday during a
visit by NATO secretary-general much of
the back-and-forth focused on Russia's
support for Syria major Garrett is at
the White House where the president made
his change of you very clear major good
morning good morning unlike his
secretary of state president Trump has
not threatened a new round of economic
sanctions to punish Russia for its
military support of Syria or its
meddling in the 2016 election but it is
clear mr. Trump is reassessing what he
can make of the Russian relationship I
think it's certainly possible I think
it's probably unlikely president Trump's
sidestepped when asked if Russia knew
ahead of time if the Syrian Air Force
was going to drop nerve gas on civilians
mr. Trump left that thorny question on
the doorstep of the Pentagon I would
like to think that they didn't know but
certainly they could have they were
there so we'll find out with
disagreements over Syria election
hacking continued violence in Ukraine
and NATO expansion the White House and
Moscow have almost no common ground
right now we're not getting along with
Russia at all we may be at an all-time
low in terms of relationship with Russia
that was not what candidate Trump
thought was meant to be we're gonna have
a great relationship with Putin and
Russia Donald Trump I think of it wants
to be friend Putin and other things she
said right I'm sending myself what's
wrong with that that's good with Russian
relations on the rocks the president has
newfound interest in NATO's ability to
project strength something he famously
doubted i said here's the problem with
NATO it's obsolete I said it was
obsolete it's no longer up Celine and in
an interview with The Wall Street
Journal the president said of chinese
government quote they're not currency
manipulators that abandoned the campaign
rallying cry
day one promise I'm going to instruct my
Treasury secretary to label China a
currency manipulator China is a currency
manipulator they're like grand chess
masters there were like checker players
but bad ones top administration
officials said the president's
conspicuous reversal plays into
negotiations with China on deterring
North Korea's pursuit of long-range
nuclear capabilities and it is that
foreign policy challenge not Syria not
Russia that is dominating deliberations
here at the Treasury Department and the
Pentagon Alex a lot to keep track of
their thanks major